Yeah.
All right, great. You're
listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio
and public radio. Neville, you are
c. N. N. P. R. Hello.
This is Jad from Radiolab a while
we work on season four of radio lab,
which we hope to release sometime in the
new year very soon in the new year we
thought we would play you some excerpts
from a talk that Robert and I gave at
the apple store in Soho.
They asked us to come talk about the
show and we ended up talking about the
thing that we never actually
address explicitly on the air,
which is how we use sound, which
we do a lot of on radio loud.
This is the one time we
actually have to talk about it,
but 250 people showed up to hear us.
I fired some clips from my laptop.
They had this big beautiful sound system
and a very fancy screen behind us and
we started the whole presentation with
a a piece of tape that got stuck in our
heads as we were making
one of our programs.
It's a little clip that became the basis
for the musical language show and we
played it for the crowd.
It happened during an interview with a
developmental psychologist by the name of
Anne Fernald.
She was talking about how moms talked
to their babies and she said this thing,
well you know,
I think it's more where we're used
to thinking of sounds like that as,
as being about something because
uh, speeches always about something,
but it feels to me more like touch
where touch isn't about something.
If you whack me on the
arm in a sudden sharp way,
I'm going to be startled or a gentle
touch has, has a different uh,
effect. And I think, you know,
actually sound is kind of touch at a,
at a distance
sound is kind of touch at a distance.
For some reason that phrase
just stayed in the air,
sound is kind of touch at a, at a distance
and it just didn't. And I thought,
well, you know, that I said to him,
well you know that actually
that's literally the case.
Cause if I'm making the sound
basically through this enhanced device,
air is pulsing. And it's going into
your ears. And actually, you know,
we could do a journey, uh, that way. We,
there's another reporter in our group
named Jonah Lehrer was up in living in
Concord, New Hampshire. We called
him. He began sending us notes.
He had a notion, which
we'll explain in a bit,
but this is then what we made and uh,
Al gonna play it to you first and then
we're going to dissect it and yeah,
you'll see when a genius
I'm working with actually.
All right. So this is, um, this is
an interview with Robert and Jonah,
which we embroidered, shall
we say, more like Tut.
It's just waves of vibrating air.
Um, it's just
into my ear. A little
ton of waves of diffuse,
vibrating air focused and
channeled into my eardrum,
which vibrates a few very small bones
and the little bones transmit
the vibration into this salty sea
where the hairs are. And the
hair cells are fascinating.
The hair cells become active when
they are literally bent by weight.
[inaudible]
Ben, like trees and a breeze.
And when these hair cells band
charged molecules
blood inwards and activate the cell. So
all those changes,
it's only when the electricity
touch sound is kind of
touch at a, at a distance.
Now I don't exactly know how he did that
and I don't exactly know. You
know, I mean at the time, well,
should I show that I like jump on your,
if you could just break it down. Sure.
Of when you open up sound in a sound
editor, it looks Kinda like that.
So you see that each of the
[inaudible] podcast listeners,
I'm going to interrupt here just to
tell you visually what happened next.
I took that scrap the sound that we just
heard sound is like touch at a distance
and I opened it in the sound editor and
it popped up on the big screen behind me
and what the audience saw was the way
form of that sentence in a way form.
It looks kind of like a mountain range.
Each little piece of sound
is like a peak or a valley.
And if it's a sharp continent, it's a
sharp peak. If it's a vowel, it's broad.
And I demonstrate it to people how
you can literally grab these little
mountains, these little hills of
sound and stretch them. For instance,
if you took the ch from touch,
just the Cha and you
grabbed it and stretched it,
he would sound something like this.
So that's true. Extended over
a long period of time. Yeah.
And you hear how it sounds, it starts
to sound a little bit like wind. Yeah.
So that plus let's take the breath
that you're just pointing to. Yes.
And let's do the same sort of, you know,
smearing of that moment
combined with the other thing.
And you get something like this
[inaudible]
that's built from an for nodes,
voice from nothing added,
nothing extra in her breath
and her, yeah, no, let's take
the tongue of touch. Yeah.
And just use that, the little grains of
sound that are in the top and then, uh,
started those and you
get something like this.
[inaudible].
So there you've got wind,
you've got a nice low sort of gravelly
watery thing going on and you've got the,
which is the, uh, the sound of the
hairs bending in the years perhaps.
And then you've got you,
you built the whole thing out of her
sentence with a few exceptions with the
bones, except for the bows, except
for some splashy splashy water.
The entire journey of sandwich you heard
a moment ago, and we'll play it again,
is built entirely of that
sentence completely and
totally from the [inaudible]
bones. I know we're
extra, right. I couldn't,
I couldn't figure out how to do
that with just, wow. It's just that
there's one last thing. Can
I just, with the electricity,
I don't know if you're wondering
that, is this the hard s on distance?
Can I have to use your imagination?
But that run through many distortion
filters in the volume jacked up becomes
this
really? Yeah. Because in a, in a,
I don't hear any or I
just hear [inaudible]
well if you can imagine that little
peak there at the very end being a much
more, um,
much more pointy and tolerant peak and
then running it through basically the
same kind of distortion pedals. I right
for everybody to listen again
to the exact same thing.
Now that you know that the entire
thing was the manufacturer from the raw
material of just one sentence.
Let's just hear it one more
time and then we'll move on.
But realize that this has been a re
this is just basically a reassembly
from the raw stuff. More like today.
It's just waves of vibrating air.
Um, it's,
yeah,
the little ton of waves
of diffuse vibrating air
focused and channeled into my
eardrums, which vibrates
a few very small bones
and the little bones transmit
the vibration into this
salty sea where the hairs
are and the hair cells are fastening the
hair cells become active when they are
literally bent by waves.
[inaudible] they bend
like trees and a breeze.
And when these hair cells
been charged, molecules
light inwards and activation itself.
Oh, so the sound triggers the bones
more like touch sound is kind
of touch edit at a distance.
Sound is also in our case we use it for
a variety of things and one of the more
important elements is at is is a kind
of paint we like emotion and feeling and
surprise and we are always trying to
goose what we've got and in a show about
minds and bodies and the
conversation between body,
brain and body that goes on constantly
and sometimes gets out of hand and
sometimes gets us confused
as to show coming up there.
So we haven't heard this
hasn't been aired yet.
There is a scene in which
we have some pilots.
These pilots have been brought into a
room and they'd been put into some kind of
a sort of a centrifuge kind
of thing. They [inaudible]
yeah, let, let me, let me,
uh, n Kara are you guys here?
Those two very fine radio
producers right there. Um,
they talked to a lot of
pilots about something that
was happening to pilots many
years ago. Pilots fly in
planes that go very fast.
And when they make these fast heart
turns, there's a tremendous amount of, uh,
gravitational force that's
applied to their person,
which if you've ever heard
the term g-forces, that's,
that's what we're talking about as the
turns get harder and faster is a very
unfortunate thing that
happens to the pilots,
which is that the blood in their brains
gets pulled violently and pools in their
abdomen and they black out,
which is not a good thing to happen
when you flying a plane. So, uh,
there was an experiment
which we wanted to profile.
And so Anne and Kara interviewed
the Guy who did this experiment.
He got a bunch of pilots
into a centrifuge,
which is this big lung 50 foot
arm that spins round and round.
And at the end of this arm is a mock
pretend cockpit pilots sit in that pretend
to fly a plane chasing an enemy
aircraft. And then all the way I'll get,
do they have to sit and do something?
They have to pretend they're flying and
it's a flight simulator essentially.
And they get spun around really fast.
And then they black out and
when they black out Jim wintery,
the researcher measures how long
they're blacked out. What happens?
Do they convulse don't they convulse
all kinds of various things.
The result and they're called back.
They try to get them to wake up.
Yes they do. No, right.
Yeah. I guess that's what saying. Um, so,
so we're going to play I guess a minute
and a half clip from that piece. Um,
they essentially they, those two
over there asked these pilots,
well what does that like
tell us about the experiment.
Give us a sort of sense
of, of, of how that,
how that was for you. Scared
pilots don't do scared.
[inaudible] 10
[inaudible]
the task was to chase
this little airplane.
So I'd sit there and you'd follow it.
And first couple of maneuvers would be,
you know, three gs g
forces as they is the,
well it's like a tick when
you're on a rollercoaster,
five gs that forest pins you back
in your seat. Yeah. Seven gs.
Except really on a roller coaster.
You're only ever going to experience
about two gs and then nine gs.
Nothing like these guys.
The Hydro g forces hurt
the skin on your face,
sags your eyelids sag so low that you
can't see out from under him and you end
up tilt your head back to look out from
under your own eyelids that are shaking
down in front of your
face. Meanwhile, yes,
you're tensing all your leg muscles
and your abdominal muscles in your arm
muscles as hard as you can. Learn
to use your body to fight it.
And what you do is you tend to every
muscle from your toes to your calves,
push it out, push it all the way
up, all the way up, okay. And uh,
you take a breath, right?
And you start to say the word Hook
and you hold it for three seconds
and then you finish it off by finishing
the k of the hook through these pilots.
They sound like they're wrestling
or fighting or something.
They're grunting and groaning and hook.
[inaudible]
making all these hook noises,
select that
the most you have ever pulled was 12.4 gs.
Now you can understand
when you listen to that,
there's a couple of tensions that
I, you know, that were introduced.
How do we know that what we've
just heard is a real thing?
All right. Our thing,
well, um, I see where you're
going with this. Um, I,
the Ed Moreau kind of
ques. Sure, sure. Um,
these are real interviews. If that's,
I mean, just to sort of clarify. Um,
they were done very much not knowing
how they would be sort of composed and
arranged in the, in the, in
the, uh, in the final product.
It just so happened in
the case of the hook,
that's just something that pilots do.
And every pilot that they talked to
made that sound and it's something,
there's something very visceral in
percussive and musical about that moment.
So when you get to that moment
where they actually do the hook,
it becomes a kind of musical event
at that point, you know, which is,
I think one of the secrets of our
notion to storytelling is that it is a
musical. You're trying, you're playing
with rhythm, you're playing with meter,
you're playing with beats. So when
you've got these sort of great vocal,
whatever those are, you just treat them
almost as, as a composer with notes.
I think you have a raw
interview with a pilot,
do you not and you have that enhanced one.
I think it'd be interesting just to hear
what it sounds like when they did it
and what it sounds like after he
abused it and then, so
let's just hear this.
Do we need to set this up at all?
This piece? Yeah, I'll do the setup.
This is a one of one of our guys
that we heard just a moment ago.
His name is Tim Sestak. He's,
if you can imagine the course of
this experiment getting spun around,
spin around, spin around
while he blacks out.
This is the moment which he comes to or
he's recalling that moment and he's in
this little pod and he has to
kind of assess the situation.
When I woke up,
I remember just sitting there and
I mean this little white space.
I actually had no idea who I was,
where I was sure what I was doing.
So I'm sitting in this little white ball
and I'm looking around and I hear this
beeping. There was this
white light beeping,
and then at that moment I realize
that I'm in a little room and that I'm
supposed to do something in that.
One of the things I'm supposed
to do is press that button.
Should I press the button? And at that
moment I realized, holy Macron a pilot.
I'm in an airplane and I'm not flying it.
And I grabbed the controls
and then just in a giant rush.
I'm Tim Sestak. Holy Mackerel.
Tim says stack. I'm Tim Stack.
I'm a pilot.
I'm flying in the centrifuge all came
back to me at once and I was okay.
Alright, so that's the
wrong sun sound design.
Let me just go right ahead
now see what you did. Do it.
[inaudible]
when I woke up,
I remember just sitting there and
I'm in this little white space.
I actually had no idea who I was, who
am I, where I was or what I was doing?
Why am I doing this?
I'm sitting in this little white ball
and I'm looking around and what is this
all about? I hear this beeping.
There's this white light beeping.
Okay.
And then at that moment
I realize that I'm in a little room and
that I'm supposed to do something in
that. One of the things I'm
supposed to do is press that button.
Should I press the button?
[inaudible]
and at that moment I realized,
holy macro on a pilot and I'm in
an airplane and I'm not flying it.
And I grabbed the controls
and then just giant run.
I'm Tim Sestak, Holly macro. I'm
Tim Sestak. I'm too obsessed. Jack.
I'm a pilot.
I'm flying in the centrifuge all came
back to me at once and I was okay.
Okay. Commando [inaudible] Dr
Minute, how are you feeling again?
Am I to go home time
now? You see there's a real
difference there. I mean, there are,
there are stunning silences.
There are times when the sounds are
slightly piled up on each other and the
instinct to do that will raise in some
quarters some questions like, you know,
like who's the, what
experience are we having here?
[inaudible] hours or he is at the same
time. I mean, here's our argument.
I mean anticipating that
someone might have this problem,
we are manipulating reality
to a degree, but it is the,
it is the music that we create.
It is in some way our sort of,
yeah, I mean how I would, how
I would put it as that. Um,
in the case of the thing you just heard,
it's a little sort of story lit that has,
you know, he's, he's in a white space.
He's doing all these
things as a story. I mean,
you have to follow the story I guess.
I mean I think people are savvy enough
to know that when you are leading them in
places that the story doesn't want
them to go. And in that moment,
I mean there are, you look for the
transfer transformation moments.
Like he has five or six points
where he wakes up, you know,
he's in a white space kind of womb.
Like all of a sudden, oh my God,
I'm in a plane, I have to fly
the plane. And then, oh my God,
I'm Tim says stack.
It's like this whole journey of life in
this little like moment and so all that
the sound is doing there,
I mean there is some emotional
information's being conveyed,
but really it's just sort of hammering
each point of transformation.
It's saying it's sort of like
in a kind of punctuational way,
it's giving a kind of
explanation point on each one
and,
and we do this to ourselves in this
sections in which we're talking back and
forth and arguing and they
are real actual conversations.
We are very conscious of the musicality.
So there will be times when he will say
basically take it down or things like
that rather frequently. Yes. Cause
I, this is like a difference in age.
I mean if,
if you're born in the fifties and
sixties and stuff or you're born in the
eighties and nineties I think you
have different jokes, different music,
different conversations in your head,
a whole different set
of how you read life.
And when I often noticed
with Ellen and Shannon,
some of the people that I have to work
with who are younger than me is I'll come
in and I'll say, okay, here's how we
should do this. The Guy, I look up to,
a follower, Robert, Robert, quiet. Yeah,
they do that. And so I
accused him of this intense,
ridiculous desire for irony and distance.
And I feel that I'm being blamed for
my own heart pounding. I an opinion
deference to you. We, you often tell us
to get interested, stop being so mellow.
And then that's also,
but we are having absolutely
a generational struggle
in the middle of all this
because what I love to hear and with he
and g and them love to hear are actually
different sounds. And so
you really whack each other.
What we end up doing in these
conversations in the studio is I go,
those are my comments. I'm
the less, I go last and goes,
we have the Lego Llamas.
I go, yeah. I said, yeah,
that was, yeah. You know, and then I
look at Ellen and I said, that was young.
That was good. And it's frankly
in comprehensible to me,
it's still even now, I mean to sort
of bring this grid, it
is the middle space,
the middle space between your
tendency toward want to sort of uh,
perform in a more forward way.
My tendency to want to kind of lean back
there is that middle ground which I I
hope to show kind of lives in,
which I neither of us could
come up with on our own. No,
and we both share it. Fairness, this
idea about touching at a distance.
Okay. Here I played a clip
from one of my personal heroes.
Walter Merge is a great film editor who
did the Godfather apocalypse now called
mountain,
a million other great movies and he's a
great thinker about editing and sound.
As far as we can tell from
the evolutionary record,
the oldest sense that we have is either
the sense of smell or the sense of touch
that that's how Ubers and bacteria is
used to navigate around in the world.
Hearing is a very refined sense of
touch and it developed of all the five
senses.
It's the latest to be
developed by living entities,
owners.
The paradox about hearing is that as
the child is growing in the wound,
it's the first of the senses to get hooked
up about four and a half months after
conception, which is to say
halfway through gestation,
the trial begins to hear now the child
was not seeing anything because it's dark
in there.
The child isn't tasting anything or
smelling anything but hearing for all
intents and purposes, the world into
which the child is developing that,
which is to say the mother's
middle is full of sound.
It's got the weather's
heartbeat 24 hours a day.
It's got her breathing 24 hours a day,
the gurgling of her intestines
at certain times of day.
It's got her voice and remembering
that the wound is pretty thin,
there's nothing to prevent
sounds from outside.
The father's a music penetrating in and
being heard by the developing child.
So sound as touch starts way, way early.
Okay. So moving right along,
we then played a clip from a segment
from our musical language show,
which looks at a particular piece of
music, Igor Stravinsky's rite of spring,
and what it can teach us about how our
brains deal with unpleasant noises.
In 1913, Stravinsky premiered the
rite of spring. It was a ballet.
Nijinsky did the choreography and when
it premiered, all hell broke loose.
Robert and Jonah layer
do the play by play.
So let's begin first. Uh, Jonah, what,
how does this, um, just set the scene?
This is May, 1913. The
spring night. It's a,
it's a balmy summer
night. Black Tie costumes.
The women have their fedoras. This
was evening clothes. Yeah. Well,
this was the Russian
ballet. This was high art.
And the program's had, this
is a concert about springtime,
but as they settled into their seats,
it turns out that what's driven ski had
in mind was not spring like honeybees.
No, this spring Stravinsky
had in mind was about change,
about radical change,
ritual murder. Literally,
that's what the story of the play is.
It's, it's a pagan ritual where the end,
the virgin gets massacred. Oh dear.
[inaudible]
but the music itself is fascinating.
The beginning is this
very charming bassoon.
It's a classic Lithuanian folk and it
does sound like the earth is warming
and that lasts for about a minute.
And then we get some Tutti
of flutes and it's lovely.
It's getting a little more disturbing.
And then about three minutes into it
[inaudible]
everything changes.
there's this, there's just an
earthquake. Stravinsky plays this cord
[inaudible]
there's a great story that when Diaghilev
who's the head of the ballet reus
first heard this cord insurance. He
was playing on the piano for him.
He asked her Wanski how long
will it go on like that.
And Stravinsky looked at him and
said to the end, my dear. And,
and it literally does that
cord structures, the music
[inaudible]
it's one of the most difficult
sounds you've ever heard. It is.
It is just the stereotype
of desinence. Yeah.
[inaudible]
it hurts you, Huh? Well what happened?
Well, after about three minutes,
they ride it. They rided
meaning what? Like they scream
or through, they scream.
There was blood old ladies were
hitting each other with canes.
One Lady Lady, she had a gun
and hit Stravinsky with a cane.
But once they started screaming,
Stravinsky ran backstage and
by some counselors crying,
the ski was off on the side of the stage
screaming to his dancers to keep the
beat. Dude. Wow. Quite the fiasco.
And the question is why,
you know,
what I love about that is that it's
three minutes simply to ask a question,
which is a question we're
interested in, which is like,
why does music sometimes create
such a like intense emotion,
not always good emotion. And the
why that we go on to sort of answer,
uh, subsequently is that,
um, there, it turns out,
and this is new science and
it's speculative science,
we should say there is,
there are already these gangs of neurons
and a particular part of your brain
called the auditory that are
responsible for decoding new sounds,
sounds that you've never heard before.
And they generally do a really good job,
but every so often they hear
sounds, which are relentlessly new,
which it was in this case. And there
it never goes back to the sounds.
They know. And in those cases,
when they fail and they can't decode the
sounds, they squirt out some dopamine.
And dopamine is not always a bad thing
and little dopamine makes you feel happy.
That's why sex and drugs and chocolate
and various things make you feel good.
But too much dopamine has been shown
clinically to cause schizophrenia.
Now we don't want to oversimplify
schizophrenia, but perhaps,
and this is the argument we put forward,
what happened that night was that their
brains flooded with dopamine and they
literally went crazy.
And then we go on to propose
that a year later in Paris,
a year later, this same guy
comes back to the same hall,
plays the same piece of music and this
time he's carried out on the shoulders of
the crowd. 25 years later,
Mickey mouse is performing this particular
piece with Tuscanini and it's become
almost kitty music. So then
we asked what happened?
How did the music that was so fear,
so new and so disturbing on Monday
become kitty music on Thursday.
And that leads to to another
notion about the brain,
that it is a very conservative organ
and it steals from artists. Yeah. Yeah.
She could have to explain that a
little bit, but I don't think I will.
But what was very cool afterwards is
it turns out that with this speculative
notion, again,
Walter Mitch will conclude with welder
merge Walter Verge on the phone with
Ellen is talking. He, we send them
the piece and say, what do you think?
And he says, not only do
I think this, I did this
well number of years ago, I was
working at a radio station in New York,
which is now defunct, called wr VR.
And I was assigned the job of
catalog in the record collection.
Then they played mostly classical
music. They had a jazz section,
but it was mostly classical music.
I found myself in the basement in a room
full of records and I was supposed to
type out a card for each of the
records and I thought, well,
I'll just use this opportunity
to teach myself musical history.
So I began at the
beginning of what they had,
which was a couple of
shelves of Gregorian chants
[inaudible]
and so for two weeks I saturated myself
in that music from nine o'clock in the
morning until seven
o'clock at night, whatever.
I went home listening to
nothing but those tonalities
[inaudible]
then for some reason I had to go up to
the control booth to ask Gordon the the
engineer or question.
So I ran up the stairs and opened the
door to this car company of sounds and,
and I,
I had for a moment exactly what I
imagined the people at the rite of spring
experienced, which was a of a
cognitive dissonance. What is this?
Why is this radio station playing
this kind of musical nonsense?
I literally clap my hands to
my ears and said, Gordon, what?
What is this music?
And he sort of casually leaned over and
picked up the album and it was box St
Matthew Passion.
No, if you've never heard buck's Saint
Matthew Passion is what it sounds like.
[inaudible]
oh, the horror.
Two weeks I had managed
without knowing it,
to reset the rural musical receptors to
the kind of music that existed before
the 16th century.
[inaudible]
we think of Bach as being in the symbol
itself of musical respectability.
And yet here I was coming suddenly and
unexpectedly upon Bar and hearing the
dissonances that are dissonant only
when you compare them with the 15th 16th
centuries.
[inaudible]
around this time we took some questions
from the audience and one came up that's
near and dear to our hearts. Someone
asked if we felt we were constrained by,
by radio, by the medium, by having no
visuals. And here's the answer we gave.
Now what I would say is that
you have to kind of reset.
But I think for a lot of
people, the, that you know,
you're cutting your carrots,
you're driving along and um,
if we are doing this right,
you should not be having that feeling
that you should actually be having
something close to a Richard
feeling. Because here's the deal.
If I'm on TV and I say to you, all right,
let's imagine a mountain and
on the top of the man lives,
but go little house on
TV. I have no choice.
I have to make the mountain my mountain
and put it on a little house, my house,
not your house and you will see it in a
piece of furniture in your room across
the distance and you will stare
at my house on my mountain.
And many of you will have some
exception about whether you don't,
it's not Emilia House,
what kind of it is that?
Whereas in this case you are unwittingly
coauthors. If I say make a mountain,
that's your mountain.
If I say add a house,
that's your house and I'm indoors,
I am in your hand already,
so it's a, I think we'll have to
just basically operate on you.
I said there are just sort of to to
play the other side for a second.
There are moments there've been one
that I could call the mind where the,
the lack of a picture
was frustrating to us.
We were doing a show about us swarming
behavior and emergence and this sort of
crowds coming together and forming a,
a personality irrespective
of the individuals and the
swarming footage of uh,
of what are those spirits
called? Starling, starling
flocking behavior. It's,
it's indescribable when
you see pictures. It,
that was the one time where were uh,
being sort of this felt like a constraint
only using sound but generally it's
about creating pictures and that are
much more rich as he was saying in,
in your brain.
I know, I'll be honest,
they are occasions where I really wished
I could be on television for certain
things. Yeah. Cause their
TV's good at some stuff. Uh,
but abstract stuff t v is
when you approach television
with an abstract thought,
television itself looks you
right in the face and it goes.
So uh, radio is a little bit more
helpful in that regard. However,
if you're murdering someone and
someone is dying and screaming, go TV,
go TV on that one.
Well that's all for now. Thanks
for listening to this podcast.
The apple store event was
produced by Alan Horn and myself.
Radio lab is funded in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting
and the National Science Foundation.
Thanks for listening.